so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Kamala Khan and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of this
video you'll have a strong understanding
of her character as well as the
significance of her creation and
introduction into the Marvel landscape
so Kamala Khan was created by editor
sana Aman
Steven wacker Adriene Alfano and writer
G willow Wilson and first appeared in
Captain Marvel issues 14 and 17 as a
background character in 2013 in an
article written by the New York Times
titled mighty Muslim and leaping off the
page sana Ahmad had stated that the
inspiration for the creation of Kamala
came during a 2012 meeting with Stephen
whacker when she had made reference to
an experience in her childhood growing
up as a Muslim American initially
whacker found the idea intriguing and in
response the two presented the idea to
writer G willow Wilson because Wilson
had established herself as an acclaimed
writer with stories like the 2008
miniseries vixen return of the lion
which focused on the return of vixen is
one of DCs first African superheroes
Marvel looked to Wilson who identified
herself as Muslim as someone who could
launch the series in a way that would
bring in readers but also respect the
Muslim belief system within the pages of
the comic to this end with Miss Marvel
number one in 2014 Wilson set about
writing Kamala Khan in a way that would
establish her as a role model for young
female readers by stepping away from the
sexualizing of female characters and
instead focus on her journey to become a
hero how her home life and family
traditions impact her decision making as
well as providing the basis behind both
the development of Khan's powers and her
adoption of the Miss Marvel name
introducing her family is being rooted
in traditional Muslim beliefs the story
also established that Kamala lives in
New Jersey now to be honest for me it's
the small things to create a more
well-rounded story and that because the
Muslim belief system forbids the
consumption or handling of pork as a
Pakistani American Kamala has to deal
with the wonderful smell of bacon and
all of its complexity while being unable
to eat it in addition to this Wilson
incorporates the idea of the
stereotypical American with the
introduction of a character named Zoey
now to be clear this isn't really
designed to insult us as readers but
instead serves the purpose of providing
us with a view of Kamala's life and
dealing with a girl
from her local school
where Zoey herself isn't being
belligerent in truth she's actually a
flake with an air Papa sness and akin to
what we would view as an individual
disconnected from reality but attempting
to solve the world's problems
to this end her lack of culture
regarding the customs of Kamala and her
friend Kiki caused her to come off as
rude when she refers to Kiki's a hijab
as a headscarf NAT a side check for a
second technically Zoey isn't wrong by
her description but the hijab is very
significant for Muslim women and that it
signifies modesty and privacy at the
same time
Zoey asked the question whether or not
kiki would be killed for taking it off
which again signifies the fact that kiki
wearing the headdress is an issue of
personal choice instead of societal
pressure from here we pick up with
Kamala and her love of superheros as one
of the elements that drew so many fans
directly to her Kamala's lo of
superheros has driven her to create
fanfiction on forms regarding
imaginative battles in this instance
she's created a story involving Captain
America Iron Man and Carol Danvers
dealing with an evil space creature
which has killed rainbow toots on Planet
unicorn while we don't know much about
rainbow toots we can probably assume
they were awesome
and as such Carol Danvers Captain
America and Iron Man deals some
much-deserved justice to the space
creature by helping it to understand the
significance of its mistake however
before the story finishes Kamala Khan is
called away by her mother for dinner at
this point the story shifts its focus to
both Kamala's family as well as the
struggles faced by young people again to
sidetrack for a second in the teenage
years of every generation a kind of
journey exists in their attempt to
figure out who they are and define their
identities for some this journey is one
of isolation and that they become
separated from their parents and only
hang out with friends and for others
it's literally bouncing between
different sets of friends within
Kamala's family her brother Amir is
searching for his identity by developing
a religious perspective of a law in
addition to this the purpose of the
back-and-forth as is presented here is
to simply establish that regardless of
the race or faith of a family's make up
the internal struggles faced by
established parents and their children's
search for identity is universal and is
really more G willow Wilson effort to
remove perceived barriers regarding the
differences between white and non-white
families
and so with Kamala being told that she
cannot attend a party held by some of
her friends and the cooler kids in
school and she travels to a room we get
this really cool inner monologue what
we're told is that for Kamala the
struggle she faces is that as a
Pakistani American all her family is
rather progressive many of the
traditional values regarding their
Muslim belief system are still
maintained the result is that in a lot
of ways
Kamala feels isolated from the rest of
the world due to her inability to eat
certain foods attend the same classes
and enjoy the same holidays as a result
and against the instructions of her
father she sneaks out of her home and
attends the party now transitioning to
the party itself this is actually
Kamala's first taste of experiencing
what life is like from the perspective
of what she considers to be a normal
American now at the outset the party
seems pretty cool and that there's live
music and dancing with all the cool kids
hanging out and talking about the kinds
of things they deemed to be important
but within this story the party provides
us with the idea that is actually a
little more than Kamala bargained for
because a Muslim belief system forbids
the consumption of alcohol the initial
reaction of Kamala is one of surprise
but her friend Bruno also expresses
anger in this now to be clear bruno
himself is actually italian-american but
because he and Kamala are friends he
also recognizes the importance of
traditional values in Kamala's life and
that despite her desire to fit in there
are also aspects of her heritage that
she cannot walk away from to this end
because there seemed to be a bed of
sorts or at the very least some of the
boys had taken joy and getting her to
consume alcohol against her religious
beliefs
Bruno guides her away when she realizes
that she was more of a target of
ridicule rather than someone people
considered a friend has something to
also take note of here is that this
point in Komodos life actually takes
place following the events of infinity
when Black Bolt had detonated the
Terrigen bomb during his battle with
Thanos the result is that the Terrigen
cloud has begun to spread throughout the
world and has finally made its way to
New York and New Jersey following this
we pick up with Kamala after succumbing
to the Terrigen mists and experiencing a
kind of surreal dream sequence of sorts
now on its face if you're unaware of the
Muslim culture this particular scene may
come across as more nonsensical than
anything else but in truth it's actually
a tribute of sorts
the words of Carol Danvers is reciting
our from a poem by a man named Amir
Khusro focusing on the beauty of the
spring season and a way to respect God
within the context of the story the
purpose of this moment is to signify
Kamala transitioning to a new stage of
existence but to also allow us as the
reader a glimpse into the beauty of her
culture and celebration of life in
addition to this were the words of
Danvers Rogers and stark tell Kamala
that she's standing at a crossroads and
that were her actions of betraying the
wishes of her parents in attending the
party were her attempt at gaining social
acceptance instead they resulted in her
being made fun of what this means is
that the hero she sees in her dream
aren't there to sway her away from
attending to mingle with American
society and instead are there to help
her understand her place in the world
and the road she needs to take to find
it to this end where Kamala remains
staunch in the face of the fact that
she's not averse to the teachings of her
parents but doesn't wish to follow them
since she doesn't see herself hailing
from that society the question is asked
about who she wants to be stating that
her desire is to be a superhero like
Danvers Rogers an Ironman she's inform
that she'll be granted her request
but the things won't necessarily turn
out the way she hopes now regarding the
bigger picture of Marvel Comics and the
Inhumans the cool thing about the entire
sequence Kamala is just experience is
that it all took place during her
metamorphosis within the cocoon formed
by the myths what this seems to tell us
is that when a new human undergoes
terrigenesis rather than experiencing
the mists and suddenly changing a kind
of journey takes place within their own
mind to help ease the transition to
their new form now I won't swear to this
since Kamala's transition is really the
only time we've ever seen the change
from within the mind of a character and
there have been several instances where
individuals emerge from terrigenesis
unaware of what's happening but
regardless as a story comes to a close
when Kamala emerges from her
transformation she's physically
identical to Carol Danvers
now following issue number one and the
introduction of Kamala Kahn G willow
Wilson actually had a work cut out for
her what I mean here is that where Miss
Marvel was initially release as a
monthly series between January of 2014
and the start of Secret Wars in May of
2015 the sales of her comics continually
dropped holding steady at around 30,000
sales each month however the reason for
this wasn't really due to a lack of
storytelling but the fact that the early
days of Kamala's publications weren't
the best for mainstream fans to gain
exposure to new creations what I mean
here is that in her first month Kamala
Kahn was competing with Scott Snyder's
Batman Jeff Jones Justice League Dan
Slott superior spider-man and Hickman's
lead up to Secret Wars in Avengers and
New Avengers however within our own
story and the remaining 40 issues of the
five-part series Wilson said about three
main tasks provide a depiction of how
Kamala's world has changed following the
development of her inhuman powers
introduced a villain and allow Kamala to
come into her own and become a heroine
all to herself
to the first with issue number two it
was established that Kamala's and human
genome allowed for combination of powers
which are identical to Reed Richards
mystique and Hank Pym now to be clear is
not that the powers of all three were
secretly planted in her it's somebody
that her in human genome works out that
way as a result she can shape-shift and
take on the form of others albeit
without copying their powers but also
extend and control the size of her limbs
as well as shrink down to smaller sizes
however despite her inner struggle and
the belief that she can't grasp
everything that's going on at the same
time
Zoe's being accosted by Josh who has
since become intoxicated by his alcohol
consumption as a result where he doesn't
indicate the intention of sexually
assaulting Zoe in his drunken state he
seems to have begun to get carried away
with himself accidentally knocking Zoe
into the water now with Kamala
witnessing the incident her struggle
begins to clear out when she references
a story her father told her as a child
what we're told is that one of the core
attendants of the Muslim Islamic belief
system is a oneness with all humanity by
way of Allah as a result if a criminal
commits a crime it's a crime against
Allah and all of humanity likewise if a
person saves a life they enhance their
ties to Allah and say
mankind using this as a basis Kamala
references our childhood and stating
that this belief coupled with her view
of the world is what led to her love for
superheroes where normal humans may or
may not have jumped in to save the day
superheroes of the Marvel Universe like
Captain America Iron Man and others
always jumped in without question even
if the battle would mean the end of
their own lives now this particular bit
is extremely important and that not only
doesn't serve as a cornerstone of
Kamala's religious faith but it also
stands as a basis behind her decision to
become a hero to this end she's able to
control her power in the context of the
situation and rescue Zoe from drowning
having said that - the second task
within these first five issues Wilson
had begun to focus on the development of
a core villain for Kamala to face within
her own comics the reason why is because
a success and popularity of heroes is
defined by the growth of their
personalities under themselves regarding
coming into their own as heroes but also
due to a rogues gallery which can be
used for the purpose to enhance the
heroes themselves but also create more
compelling stories in addition to this
the nature of the villain has to match
the hero meaning that for Kamala it
wouldn't make any sense to have her face
off against someone capable of working
reality instead she would need someone
to complement her powers but who could
also resent a challenge to this end in
issues three four and five Wilson
maintained Kamala's hero worship of
Carol Danvers but also combined it with
her desire to become her own hero as a
result during a visit to her friend
Bruno at his deli she unwittingly walked
in on a robbery taking place now the
initial intention of Kamala is to alert
the authorities to what's happening but
because her phone's died the only
options available to her are to either
allow the robbery to take place or to
intervene and stop it choosing the
latter when she makes yourself known she
actually appears in the form of Carol
Danvers using her powers of molecular
manipulation and quite literally
smashing the cashier's desk her first
act and going against the armed criminal
actually isn't that bad something that's
also interesting here is that during her
attempt to stop the robbery
she actually celebrates her actions in
effort Kamala she feels as though her
life finally has purpose now the reason
why I like this is because it's not
something we normally see from
superheroes
throughout both Marvel and DC as well as
other publishers including valiant it's
usually a kind of unwritten
understanding that heroes come into
their own and oftentimes it takes place
off panel with Steve Rogers for example
one day he was a sickly human being and
within the same day he was had the peak
of human conditioning where his early
stories in the 1940s and his role in the
Avengers in the 1960s saw him battling
the forces of evil
there wasn't much emphasis on him coming
to grips with his new abilities but
transitioning back to our story in the
midst of her attempts to subdue the
criminal Kamala Kahn is actually shot
through this stomach now the importance
of this is that it allowed Wilson to
move Bruno into the realm of a sidekick
of sorts and that when he calls for help
from emergency services in an effort to
rescue who he believes to be Carol
Danvers
Kamala reveals her identity to Bruno
telling him who she truly is now again
this is all part of the larger picture
regarding Wilson tying Kamala in to most
of the superhero archetypes that exist
at the time what I mean here is that if
we took Batman for an example a staple
of his existence is that Alfred is well
aware of Bruce's escapades as a Caped
Crusader and even helps him to achieve
his goals regarding the bigger picture
of Kamala's first villain this goes
towards the idea that Kamala herself
would have some measure of an ally
against the various foes as she would
have to cope with and so following this
or the next issue and a half focus on
Kamala and Bruno tracking down the
robber who was revealed to be Bruno's
younger brother named Vick Kamala's
first villain in the form of inventor
was revealed in the final page of issue
number 5 as a man named Thomas Edison
now where issue 7 to 11 would explain
that the inventor is the result of a man
named Knox cloning the original Thomas
Edison who had created a light bulb by
way of Tesla during the cloning process
Knox's pet bird had become mingled in
the cloning procedure causing Edison to
be cloned as a human avian hybrid
however despite these early attempts to
establish Kamala as a strong female
character her stories didn't quite gain
the following that both Marvel and
Wilson were looking for and that her
publications continually slumped in
sales looking to the Avengers and other
teams as a way to boost the popularity
of Kamala's character with issue number
6 and number 7 as well as 10 and 11
Wilson introduced several team ups with
Wolverine the Inhumans and even
Loki of Asgard where the purpose of
these was to provide a larger picture
regarding the various schemes that the
inventor had implemented in attending to
see if it was possible to get people to
act against their own best interests and
truth it wasn't so much the team-ups
that piqued the interest of fans as much
as it was Kamala's interest in seeing
these various individuals with will rain
for example because he was such a
well-known hero in the superhero
community albeit with an antihero stance
he had been a major source of Kamala's
fanfiction in relation to storm and so
for her meeting Wolverine was tantamount
to one of us meeting a celebrity we had
spent most of our lives idolizing with
the Inhumans the meeting between Medusa
and Kamala is educational and that
Kamala was informed that unlike
Wolverine speculations she's not a
mutant and instead is an inhuman now
this particular bit is important and
that Kamala didn't know about the
Terrigen cloud spreading across the
world and it simply attributed the mist
to some sort of weird phenomenon that
resulted in her gaining abilities
furthermore the education came with a
caveat and that were Kamala possessed
the power to heal and shape-shift the
more she heals from injuries the less
she's able to shape-shift however
despite these interesting team ups in
these concepts the problem that Wilson
and fans faced was as Secret Wars and
all-new all-different marvel was
lingering on the horizon
meaning that almost all information
regarding Kamala her abilities how they
worked and who her allies were had to be
crammed into a small number of comics in
a short amount of time having said that
were Kamala's first volume technically
lasted 19 issues the final four issues
of this series were part of the last
day's line which saw Danvers and Kon
teaming up leading into the collapse of
the multiverse now the importance of
Kamala and Carroll teaming up is
something that cannot be overlooked to
be honest for me it felt like the entire
series of stories as they were released
under the banner of Miss Marvel vol 3
had all been leading up to this point
the reason being because this team-up
was just as much a reflection of Kamala
idolizing Carol Danvers as it was a
reflection of women in comics what I
mean here is that as the publication's
of Kamala progressed the idea behind it
was to create a character who is
pakistani-american and a woman which
would go on to empower young girls and
provide a place for them among the
pantheon of male heroes in addition to
this for both
Kamala and Carol Danvers fans the last
days comics were passing of the torch so
to speak and that there had never been
an instance in Kamala stories where she
had officially received the blessing of
Carroll and undertaking the mantle of
Miss Marvel and operating accordingly
where some of the more die-hard fans of
Carol Danvers weren't necessarily
pleased to see this happen for a large
majority of model readers even if it
wasn't the most important of events to
take place considering everything that
was going on at the time I always felt
like it was a significant moment for
Kamala herself now to focus on this for
a bit when it comes to women in comics
there's only a handful and Marvel that
have actually stood the test of time as
being unshakeable members of the
superhero community as one of the first
major heroines to receive her own series
Carol Danvers stands atop the list
alongside Ororo Munroe and Susan storm
as such Carol had played a major role
for young female readers looking to get
into comics and that they had a hero of
sorts that they could call their own
and so much like these young girls
Kamala Khan reflected this desire for a
hero to idolize and found it in Carroll
however because the collapse of the
multiverse and all things with end was
imminent this team-up wasn't so much
about Kamala and Danvers fighting
villains together as much as it was
about fans of Kamala receiving the comic
they had been waiting for but also
Wilson providing us with a view of
Kamala
receiving her one big wish of fighting
alongside Danvers even if only for a
moment now having said all that once
all-new all-different levels started
like most of Marvel's lineup the stories
of Kamala took place eight months after
the end of Secret Wars with no
information regarding what took place
during that time as a result there's not
much to offer here in terms of a
discussion since we're only a few issues
n however there are some things we can
talk about with issue number one and
with G willow Wilson returning to the
title as writer Kamala was introduced as
being part of the all-new all-different
Avengers led by Sam Wilson and operating
alongside Tony Sarg Sam Alexander Jane
Foster vision and why
Morales in addition to this where Bruno
he confessed his love to Kamala during
the final issues of mismo vol 3 but was
rejected the sentiment seems to remain
the same in that Kamala still desires to
focus solely on her role as a hero
sparing a little time for anything else
simultaneously Wilson elected to broaden
the character of Bruno by moving him
from the friend and sidekick harboring
an unrequited love to a man that has
since moved on and found his own romance
with a woman named Michaela Miller but
again because we're only two issues in
there's really not much to offer besides
this but if you are currently reading
Kamala Khan or if you're on the fence
about it then post a comment below and
let me know what you think so far and
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and that will
catch you guys later peace